holy [__] [__]
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy [__] [__]
is the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
oh language the baby's here
yo what up everybody roaring Kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is
GameStop I love this guy
[Applause]
retail Traders I'm hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it looks like there's one guy
driving all the buying
money man happy to take it
Wall Street
is betting that this company is gonna
fail if it fails these hedge fund
[__] make a [__] ton of money
70 000 people have watched this video
[Music]
he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
GameStop those shares not stopping no
stock it's only gonna go up when they
hit I'm gonna buy you a mansion a string
to that my brother is a [__] nerd
Wall Street must be seeing this right
holy [__] [__] holy [__] you should
probably dial in holy [__] [__] do
you have a minute I uh
um
babe how much did we make today
five million how much did we lose today
a billion and yesterday 4 million and
yesterday a billion
yeah
like [__] rich
Rich dude's pissing in their pants right
now they're coming after we need to talk
about the Game Stop situation
retail Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated
surprise surprise you have to testify
before Congress the game has changed
[Music]
what's the point of winning the race if
you let some deep [__] steal the prize a
lot of people feel the system is broken
the whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune certainly
not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
[Music]
pit balls
maybe now there is [__] yeah
[Music]